hello everyone
good afternoon here from cloudy
california
gamespot live we're back we're back for
day two for part two
of the call of duty event yesterday a
lot happened also let me know if you can
hear me yes
good what's up chat um yesterday a lot
happened a lot to unpack
and part two is going on today so just
to recap
aaron and i are waiting
hopefully to get into the server soon we
have eric on standby
in the server queue trying to check out
which which approach works faster we're
just trying to get in you know
um but thank you for joining us
yesterday verdansk
got nuked and we were
all just sort of pushed to rebirth
island and now we're gonna figure out
what happens next a lot of rumors going
around a lot of fun rumors going around
so we're here to confirm
everything all right cool thank you chad
everyone is saying
looking good sounding good so great
we're here to talk about i mean while we
wait we might as well just
talk about what's going on um for those
of you who did miss
the event yesterday um
we we had a two-hour window where you
got to play verdansk
one more time and it was infected with
zombies
and everything just you know verdance
was lost
and there was no other option to there
was no exfil option they tried
but it it got overrun and
it had to get nuked that was the only
option for those of you who missed it
yesterday i'm sorry it was
it was a window a small window and the
servers were kind of funky so
you know we're trying to do our best
here to get into a lobby
um we might have to actually back out of
this we'll see how it goes because
it's 12 and we didn't aaron and i here
on the screen
didn't kick over to a new playlist or we
didn't get a playlist notification
update
but
uh yeah okay so we will just have to um
i'm hearing uh
eric tay correspondents in my ear
telling me that a lot of streamers a lot
of people are going through the very
same thing right now so we're gonna hang
back
open for any questions you guys might
have
um let me get the chat actually running
up see how everyone's doing today we've
got
live streaming everywhere we got the
gamespot
main youtube page the trailers channel
facebook i believe
so hello to everyone part two is online
the chat is saying this
is uh yeah this will take a while so
just like yesterday we appreciate your
patience let us know
in the in the chat uh how it's going for
you guys people you know
people loved to keep us updated in the
chat yesterday and be like oh i'm in
all the server crashed this and that so
we're learning
how this is playing out together so
appreciate your patience and uh your
correspondence here in the chat today
part two is now online
20 minute queue people are saying
playlist
update
okay i see okay so people are
are just now starting to get in i'm
hearing from eric tay that little by
little
uh only a handful of people are actually
getting in
most people are saying 20 minutes just
like um just like yesterday the server
queue
server's getting smashed right now and i
think they let
um yesterday because of this i think
they let the playlist
ride out for another like 20 minutes or
so i mean i hope that's why
a lot of people are saying i see you
guys in chat a lot of people are asking
me to just restart the game
um let me ask eric tay if if you're
still in the queue
uh how's it looking on your and eric tay
okay so he's telling me that he's in the
server queue kind of like yesterday
where
um he's just seeing a screen there we go
oh
updating playlist look at that it popped
up for just a second but nothing
happened
did you guys see that on stream um so we
still have the same things here eric's
telling me that he's in the server queue
waiting
uh with a 18 minute clock that's not
moving so
it's looking rough for all of us
people are saying hey hey what's up chad
people are saying going
backing out once might help because the
playlist update just happened
um you know it might wait another minute
here because
all in all in the end that did help for
us yesterday while we were in the server
queue
today we just have a you know a second
approach here just
being in the lobby we'll see if that
helps aid us at all
but in a minute here if it doesn't work
maybe backing out one time and seeing if
the playlist update took effect
um some people in the chat are saying
don't restart it's stuck at the fetching
profile
yeah we're getting a lot of mixed things
here so we'll sit back for a minute
um we did see just now that the playlist
update popped up on our screen
uh but i do have a feeling in a moment
here we just will have to like
back out and refresh see if anything
changed but
i'm also talking to eric tay who says uh
nothing has changed on his end he's on
the
server screen that we all saw yesterday
yeah okay uh kellen in the chat says oh
yeah game spot back out that's what i
did and it put me in the queue
okay yeah i'm not even in a queue right
now we did see the playlist update
flash for a second but another minute
here i think we will
need to try that um unless we get word
from eric day that something's changing
uh but he did say eric uh is right here
in my ear and he did say that some
people are slowly getting in so this is
good news
it's deja vu of yesterday i'm gonna sit
here and talk for a while
but that's all right we've got a lot
going on today
and uh thank you all for being here like
it's it's all the waiting game so we're
kind of just
hanging out until until something
happens but i see you guys all in chat
thank you so much
one uh someone in the game spot trailers
chat said it bro i'm here
you gotta restart someone's in school no
i don't like to see those comments y'all
better not be
in school and watching this it's not
worth it stay in school
focus on school i don't like those
comments you guys come on now
this is cod it'll always be around you
got to stick it out for school
ah someone else restarted in chat and
said now i'm stuck
someone else said i got a squad going
yeah we are
a lot is happening right now folks so
thanks for sticking around
while we figure it out um yes
interesting okay
yeah that's what i might try to do
eric tay is telling me that nick marks
is getting in he was where i was right
now he backed up
once and then you know uh hit x again
i think i might do that eric if it's
cool i might just give that a shot
what do you think any any major
objections
yeah i mean it looks a little more
promising than this i feel like i'm
stuck in this like
okay so chat here we go i'm gonna back
out for a sec just to this screen
because the playlist update did happen
hit warzone again look at that for
destruction of her dance part two
there's oh now i'm getting all of this
okay
now there we go
let me uh try to let me confirm that
aaron is here looks like he is so let's
give this a shot
looks like we're in folks thank you all
for your patience we've got a lot to
cover here and i wanna
i'm here for questions uh but first i
just wanna show you how it's gonna play
out
so you can see it for yourself it looks
like we got through
oh man aaron is not in my lobby anymore
okay here we go
aaron says after the playlist update we
got separated but
that sucks because when i came back to
the playlist update
you were still in my party
okay let's just uh go with what we know
here
we're back on rebirth island waiting for
the lobby to fill which is the silliest
thing i've seen all day because
everyone's trying to get into this game
but i have my loadout that's interesting
all right
we're in guys should you restart uh
depends where you're at chat uh someone
like if you just saw what i was doing
um hostile drop it into the area watch
the sky i was in like the lobby and then
i uh
i backed out to the warzone splash
screen and then i pressed x again that
might work for you
that's just what worked for me
uh but i lost aaron aaron sampson maybe
we can get in uh the next game
together
all right just running around waiting
for this to happen let's go
wish me luck um i think this is a yeah
it's a team of four so that's good news
you guys saw i might have caught the
stream yesterday on rebirth island
me alone like i'm not i need help i need
help
was there was that the official trailer
yes this morning the official trailer
dropped
and it was full of rappers and
celebrities and
i felt very old because i know i knew
none of them i mean
they are still fighting in verdansk
keeps them
it sounds oh you hear that that's the
event that's the
sound we got yesterday too enemy
is this a new map no it is ah it is
rebirth island but it's at night so it's
it's different
but this premiered yesterday but now
we're gonna see
if the story elements continue into
uh uh today's playlist should this is
the ending that what was it the
destruction of her dance
party boruto's dad in the chat back
what's all right guys wish me luck i'll
be a little
a little in the chat copy your mark just
so i can try to focus get some good
gameplay for you guys
talk amongst yourselves
we need to clear all enemies and gather
valuable intel before it's overrun
okay that's what i kept hearing this is
it soldier destroy the dance
save the world oh boy
so we make the call from here the nuke
like must get launched
from here and it seems like we have to
do it
so wish us luck i already goofed and
missed my shot hey but we have our
loadouts this is good this is good what
the
all i know damn
oh now the container and now
that's my punishment the zombies are
coming because i entered the
incredibly wrong password
there's the new pbsh by the way tactical
nuke device deploying
oh shoot look at that countdown guys on
the top everything's changing
everything's happening
i think no matter what we're gonna all
see
what happens here which is nice look at
my friends aren't even worried we kind
of just are like what's going on here
what's going on here
someone in chat says i look like your
friend marty oh right must be a handsome
dude
where's my friend
yeah there's a there's a lot going on
without anything going on i'm just kind
of sitting here
um and i don't want to i don't want to
die or anything i kind of just want to
see what happens in 18 seconds so be
patient with your chat looks like it's
going to happen
very soon
i also kind of want to see it like let
me see if i can find a good window
five seconds five seconds what's gonna
happen
i'm looking for a launch that guy's
actually still he's doing things out
there tactical
device inbound oh look one hold the
device
until it's ready for activation hold the
device until it's ready okay
we have to be the team to do so now it's
going to be a bloodbath watch this
i knew it someone's already chucking all
right
come on team let's move let's move i'm
being
it keeps sniped wish me luck guys i'm
just going to run for it hopefully
people aren't being
that mean because i kind of want to see
what happens
sorry i'm sorry
that guy has it okay you see how it
works now okay i'm learning here and i'm
glad i'm not dead yet
let me reload everything and just see
okay that dude dropped it i wonder how
long you have to hold it oh there's the
timer up top okay
i'm rambling but uh i'm learning also
wish me luck
i was able to pull that off you're a
strong boss that you'll make it yeah
rose you got this
come on we have the device okay
oh i was trying to hide for a second
no matter what happens guys it looks
like the counter is going up
so we're going to see the nukes launch
no matter what
fine i got you chad is saying that timer
is nonsense
this
[Music]
yeah this is capture the flag for a nuke
he didn't even pick up the nuke he
didn't even pick up the name
cool can we respond yeah look at that
guys i haven't blinked in like five
minutes this is crazy
exciting stuff where's the nuke there we
go
it's gonna be it's gonna be hot this
entire time until that
time or that percentage hits uh
there's a guy down there
[Music]
and i have all the attachments to make
it less crazy so
it might look that way
look 95 you guys
okay
i just want to see it happen i don't
want to miss it
no and i might
tactical ready for activation all right
guys it looks like
we're at 100 now nobody killed me
activated wait
give us a chance
you did what you had to do you saved us
all
right here we go
nothing more we can do it's over
well these are our winners here they're
the ones who got to actually nuke
for dansk and confirmed the
new codes were launched or the nuke was
launched from rebirth island
we had to do it
whoo
i'm back out here
[Music]
so
you have no idea what's coming
here we go guys confirmed we got nuked
back
into the 80s look at looking for dance
effect
we are back for dansk 2021 is gone
and we have for dance 1984.
it's happening here's the duga array
oh it's so nice to finally be able to
talk about this look at you can stand up
here
shoot people there's a lot of new points
of interest so let's look around
right now my teammates are flying in
they want to go to the stadium i'm going
to say hell no and be a bad team player
but it's so i can show you guys of
course i want you guys to see to look
around with me
this is for dance as we know it now this
is
1984 verdansk welcome
yes more people in the chat are saying
that their servers are getting
our servers are online and more people
are getting in you're losing ground
good good good all right i want to find
a car just to like take a tour or
there's a car up ahead so i will look at
this flowers on for dansk
ain't that nice people love
to uh talk about how her dance was very
brown and like plain and i agreed but
like um this is nice this is a
little little touches here make it look
a lot nicer
so i want to show you guys some very hot
points of interest
let's take a tour for dansk uh i'm not
playing the objective at the moment
because
it's back to vr as normal and i want to
show you guys what it looks like to
drive around
see here okay it's not that big
currently so i can only take us
so far uh let me take you guys to
the salt mines
but we'll keep playing you guys uh i
think you know i don't have to do that
rebirth event anymore
as far as i know let's have a look
around
there's the duga array or at least a new
you know
a big antenna array up there
there's the stadium
that's where all my friends are i'll go
back there later i do i just want to
show you guys how it looks
yeah it is a uh it is a 1980s version
of verdansk so we got new we got nuked
back into the 80s
differently
crane over here
here's cory guys it's a salt mine
that's exciting it's not i what i like
about this
i saw it um what i like about this is
that it's not so
uh there's not a crater anymore there's
just salt lines here which is nice
excuse my driving and my sensitivity i
hope you guys are enjoying
the tour i'm just trying to get you guys
to have a look here at what's new and
what's what's still around
awesome people in the chat still can't
get in
keep trying guys it helped me to back
out and get into the server
friendly loadout drop on the way
looking around here's the base of the
which is nice
it's looking good so far i mean yeah it
is a a re-skinner
you know any change is good i think
verdansk was good at its core it was a
big kind of maybe a little too open of a
map
you know it's all we knew except so uh
so some touches like this i think are
are nice here's the tv station
a new map would have been cool but i
mean rpg or hard drives right
so i like oh i'm stuck
i like what i'm seeing so far it isn't
yeah a incredibly massive overhaul
but there are some points of interest i
was trying to show you but now they're
out of the map
like everything's you know i'm getting
uh caught by this boat so
maybe maybe next month i'll show you
guys and all my friends are alive maybe
i'll head to them
and see if we can survive together they
seem to be doing fine
don't know how i made it out of there
no
it's a little more green
there's the stadium halfway
oh there we go let's test
[Applause]
now go get them
yes for those of you just tuning in well
uh this
is verdansk in 1984. it is
similar in a lot of ways but there are a
lot of changes that have been made right
now we are currently under stadium
in the 1980s it wasn't even completely
built yet this is what it looks like on
the inside
and i'm holding the new carve2 rifle
[ __ ] drive
sheesh all right cool
i'll follow you guys looks like we will
be uh driven around some people in the
chat are not impressed i mean
verdance is for dance right i mean i get
it but i think
enough changes here uh maybe not
revitalize the gameplay and stuff but
definitely refreshed it
so it'll keep us busy for a while yeah
we're getting sniped what is this dude
doing the driver come on
and the gas is coming so
and we left our car in there i shouldn't
have gotten in the car without me
friendly all right i'm getting away from
aaron simpson that he is in
oh nice okay cool i could have used that
armor
hey look a tunnel here we're gonna find
a lot of little things like this i'm
sure
in the process it's like when apex you
know got uh
was it like bombarded and there was lava
everywhere that was cool
this is similar to that and i liked that
update so
but continue to let me know how you guys
feel
they'll fight for a chance to redeploy
i'm not streaming to hear my own voice
i'm streaming so you guys can check it
out with this
inbound marking new safe zone and
hopefully get some
nice gameplay look at this truck
oh i'm hearing from aaron that after the
rebirth thing he wasn't let onto the new
map that's so strange
looks like we're seeing some issues
today
knock that [ __ ] off oh i got in the way
of that shot
man you stole my armor your teammate is
redeploying standby
there's a stadium downtown is barely
built
this might be it for us
[Applause]
mean price price 84.
by someone over here
oh they're at the stadium they're gonna
have to push to us let these guys try to
take us on never mind yeah look at that
feeling tough now in the smoke
oh i got hit all right maybe i should
get the hell out of here
see what's up with the friends
you ain't got time to rest yeah
let's go get in the car
oh we didn't finish reviving that guy
now go get him
[Music]
you guys like my horn come on get in i
got shotgun
this suv forget all these people trying
to snipe us
now's a good time to get out of here see
if we can explore some more of the map
apparently i'm playing with uh gato
enemy uav overhand all right cool this
looks like a nice
all right there's another suv here i
just want to get some coverage
being shot at from every they're on me
so let's see
okay let's get out critically we'll hold
up in here
it's nice to have my whole team uh
normally by now my team is you know
toast okay i'm gonna lay low because
i feel like every window i check out i'm
gonna be hit with a hail of bullets
who got hit oh he went too far
shoot
can you crawl to me
relocating i wonder where he got hit
from though i'm not gonna go out there
and like
risk my neck
am i being baited god i don't know what
to do guys i'm a bad team player
forget it come on don't worry you'll
survive
chassis moving
where'd you get hit oh man now the other
guys are getting hit
yes uh for the chat yes yesterday the
dance got nuked
we played on rebirth island where we
learned that that's where the nukes came
from
and after verdance got nuked we were
sent back
to 1984
and we're playing that map right now
there's a lot of new points of interest
things have been added to the verdance
map um
and a lot of things stayed the same but
uh it's a big oh it's a big old 80s
version of the map and i'm trying to
hide in the perfect spot so i don't get
like
hit with anything by anyone here here we
go here we go here we go
this is after the nuke deployed
[Applause]
seeing all these youtubers are getting
on i don't know like
i don't know that's got to be some weird
coincidence like we don't have i was in
the server for
half an hour yesterday i did definitely
got no special treatment there
by the way guys the gulag has changed
and it is now standoff listen up so
the old black ops two man
you're up soldier now go sort this
[ __ ] out
i got two kills and i'm not i'm not a
high player but
my goal here was to show off the map and
the events of what happened so i'm just
going to keep saying that
leave the game okay let me see if uh
aaron is available
to hop in gamespot's very own aaron
sampson let's see if he's down to play i
think he's on rebirth island currently
um and i can't invite him
that's all right let's see here but this
is what it looks like
there's a new splash screen in the
background you know
let me see what's going on with chat
here uh i love not being able to play
yeah uh i don't know i got i got lucky
today it happened a lot faster than it
did yesterday
as far as tackling the server issues uh
but keep trying you guys uh
yesterday it helped for me to restart
today it helped for me to back out of
this screen and go to the main screen
you know the playlist update kicked in
and
i got lucky um so let's try again
hopefully we get to see more of
the um the new dance map the updated for
dance map
smokey kush cheese for the rat a lot of
interesting names i probably should have
turned on that streamer mode
okay here we go i think we have to go
back to rebirth island
to see how it plays out
i haven't noticed you guys um if modern
warf
on verdance 84 if modern warfare weapons
were
removed i will check on that next time
good question
i don't think so like i don't think so
some of the guns weren't even created
you know they weren't even made in 1984
but we're
you know we are we are what's the term
um
they are still fighting in verdansk
uh our suspension of disbelief is in
play right now
but yeah i didn't see any you're right i
didn't see any modern warfare maps
play time's over mate you're going to
the war zone here we go
this is a good recap for those of you
just joining
this is what's going on we are at
rebirth island just like yesterday
except this mode is sort of a capture
the flag mode
where you gotta hang on to the flag aka
the nuke
in this case for as long as you can if
you're able to hold it
be the last person holding it you're the
one who gets to nuke for dance it's all
your fault but um
last time we tried last time i tried the
destruction of the dance
okay we got to see it happen but we're
not breaking but reaching critical mass
we need to clear all enemies and gather
valuable intel before it's overrun
this is it soldier destroy the dance
save the world
all right my team just jumped they said
well yeah you start with your loadout i
don't want this gun i want my old gun
back
okay this room is thoroughly explored
but yeah there we go as soon as the
infection rate rises all the way we have
to get the
the nuclear codes the little tablet
thing that'll be soon
activate the launch device hear that
tactical nuke device deploying soon
okay i wonder where it'll deploy
it's randomized but uh let me in this
damn window
okay thank you guys for for tuning in i
hope you guys are able to get in
yourself
but if not i hope you're enjoying this
stream today for this event
um because it's crazy like this is part
two of
the destruction of her dance we saw a
lot happen yesterday and we're seeing
more happen today
i heard someone land
this is just like yesterday the zombies
have taken over her dance and we're here
at
island trying to figure out what to do
next
and we're gonna nuke it that's the plan
wish me luck
the enemy has the device it's okay you
can kill the enemy and grab it yourself
being sniped poorly
trying to get to the device trying to
get to the device
where is it oh my homies are down
there's too many zombies we have to get
out
trying to get to the device i'm close
i'm close
oh man they're they're cutting all the
cords they're cutting all the ties we're
about to nuke for dance
let me up this damn hill please oh
i'm close to the device all these hills
i hate alcatraz
oh sniper cracks we're still fighting
soldiers
guys got a little quiet there because i
got so close but
yeah if you win and you have the nuke
device
[Music]
shoots it down it's upstairs that's
annoying
wish me luck friends wish me luck hang
in there chat i want to
see if i can sneak in and get this
he's upstairs i gotta figure out where
the stairs are
yeah no matter what we will see what
happens so i just wanted to be the one
responsible
people are just kind of camping out also
how did he
more people are getting into the game
according to check some good news
a chance here we go
i'm gonna back out here so you guys can
enjoy this
nothing more we can do it's over
nick that's a good question earlier on
rebirth island oh you know what
i'll talk later
[Music]
so
you have no idea what's coming
welcome to verdansk 84. for those of you
just joining
objectives okay for those of you just
joining we got nuked back into the 80s
there for dance 2021 is toast waypoint
and we are here in 1984 look at the duga
array over here
nice
coordinate this guy wants to go to
quarry which is now the salt mines
these are the salt mines now there's not
so it's not so dipped into the ground
and stuff time to go find adler chad is
saying
yeah really the hunt for adler is uh you
know
supposed to be the next thing
i want to show you guys around as much
as i can that's my goal here uh but
as far as gameplay we're back to regular
vr this is it
i'll just go join my friends over here
a lot of little things have changed um
and a few big things have changed
but this is for dansk in the 80s so
essentially
at its core it's a familiar map
oh yeah i will be on the lookout for
modern warfare guns that was a good
question from chat to see if um
ground loot or any weapons
from modern warfare can be played from
black ops
and i'm really interested it would make
sense that the ground loot is all black
ops because they're really you know
they're just pushing
black that's the ak from black ops
okay good eyes chat good eye
i really don't see any ground loop for
modern warfare weapons but i'm sure our
loadouts will be fine i'll show this i'm
sure they'll still work
another one
but let me know in the chat how you guys
are doing hopefully you guys were able
to get on yourself
um because of her dance yesterday
is gone the verdance we we knew
it's gone it is now permanently for
dance 1984. i thought that was an
openable door excuse me
another yeah another black ops 1911 no
ground loot has been
for modern warfare again narratively it
makes sense but um
uh um our loadouts should remain
fine if you can't use half the guns then
that'd be really dumb so i doubt that's
even an issue
this guy keeps going up and down in his
helicopter
let me see here should i push i'm alone
he's alone
repositioning all right let me go down
push
i'm a friendly push
oh wait he's got more friends
damn this pharah i think i must have
been weak already
that was so stupid and i'm alone what am
i doing i just
i just committed suicide that's it
they're gonna come for me and i'm toast
maybe because all my friends they left
look at this look how far i am i was
just trying to
look around and chat with chat here oh
well
um maybe they'll buy me back i've been
i've been a pretty bad teammate so i
doubt it but
i just wanted to show you guys around
okay i should have had that
i was 90 sure i did have that
because they have a stronger weapon but
hey we get to check out the gulag so
that's good news the gulag has also
updated which is great
that's a hot take richard in the chat
says this is why i moved to apex at
least they have new maps
i mean i can't disagree with that this
is a this is essentially a reskin but
so far from what i've from what i've
played um i like it it's it's a refresh
is like
leaps and bounds better than doing
nothing so
but i get it welcome to the gulag if you
survive you earn your freedom
wait for your turn now okay are you
ready the
if you can't tell which you probably
can't because it just looks like a bunch
of wood
the new layout for the gulag is standoff
if you
it's the black ops 2 map uh if you
google standoff you'll know
you'll see that one picturing you will
remember exactly what it is
um but standoff is also an area that i
haven't been able to get to
but it is on the new warzone map it's
near the gulag
outside of the gulag there was a big
open field they added the entire
standoff map
into that area time to earn your freedom
so
come on oh my god got roughed up in
there we're bringing you
sorry guys well let's spectate for a
while i could finally
just keep up with the chat see how
everyone's doing um nick yeah the keypad
uh there was a keypad on rebirth island
and it was like a uh
god it felt like a ten digit keypad or
something like that
and i don't know where you find out the
password
i just jokingly put in six nine six nine
six nine that didn't work
uh but i wonder what it is i'm correct
like we went to a uh aaron sampson and i
went to a
uh aaron sanchez i was doing a
presentation that treyarch held and
raven they didn't talk about that at all
so there's definitely some more to
uncover
is the engine the same yeah i don't
think uh an engine re-haul would have
been possible
oh christian chat says i hate standoff
that's all right oh i'm back they
brought me back
shitty teammates look at these guys well
we're landing on a new point of interest
here the duga array
you can fight i love to say this but you
can fight up here on the tippy top of
these things
you can snipe up here kind of hang out
up here it is
oh [ __ ] well r.i.p me
psych marking aid station all right
let's see what we can find but yeah look
at this
those two watch out homeboy left me with
a shotgun better than nothing
but yes look around look at this very
nice
very tall uh it's one of the bigger oh
man the map is shrinking but
check it out um prison i think around
here is the standoff area if i'm not
mistaken no port
where is it
boneyard okay so the labels are pretty
much the same they're not summit that's
a new area also
the summit map from black ops one
has made its way into warzone that's
huge i forgot about that
[Applause]
the new carve two weapon the burst rifle
hell yes oh my friends are fighting i'm
gonna go help
[Applause]
i got you brother
assist i didn't do anything but i will
take credit for that okay
city in the chat says buy me a tesla um
buy me one first man
i need ammo for gas inbound safe zone
relocated
enemy uav overhead let's pick up here no
he does that
excellent
so we thought this burst rifle
we thought the burst rifle was going to
be the g11 it was rumored
because of the game uh
you're too kind i think i want a new
weapon
ppsh is also now in the game
in war zone officially but i'm not that
good with it so i'm going to switch for
the ak which i know i'm better with
wish me luck but yes shout out to evan
what's up
game spots very good repositioning evan
evan langer
my team is moving my team is hungry for
these kills
check out the okay chat wants me to
check out the ppsh next one i pick up
next one i see i will pick up um it's
fun but it's a little jumpy and i gotta
get used to it
and you know i wanted some good gameplay
i don't want to just die as soon as i
come across someone which has already
happened a bunch of times
do i do you need to win to be allowed
onto the new map no
it is a narrative storytelling way to
get you onto
verdansk84 but no matter what it gets
nuked
you can help nuke it you probably get
like a calling card or something you can
nuke it
but uh you don't have to if you even if
you lose i lost
right here like twice on stream and um
you still get got a vehicle here on this
new map for dance 84.
we have another evan in the chat what's
up evan my guys
objective is to eliminate the bounty
target oh
enemy precision [ __ ] stay doors stay
indoors find a bathroom
hux in the chat says the ppsh has the
icon of the mac 10 yeah
in the in the menus and everything the
ppsh
is being identified as a um [ __ ]
as a mac 10. like they haven't got the
files
safe zone relocated
all right this team has been carrying me
if you
so shout out to my team here because
perfect not doing much
but they're making it so that we get
some like decent game play we're staying
alive together here
so thank you to my team
i did want to show you around peacefully
but no way you know i can't be able to
it's still br you know it's still oh my
god
i'm on the fire
what is this fence
go load up boys i gotta arm her up
i should get inside
okay anything left um
no i want to use this rifles too i like
this rifle
and i've had good luck with this rifle
but yeah guys i'm confirming it so far
no ground loot oh [ __ ]
is uh from modern warfare oh my god move
did i say that i'm a bad teammate
already yeah bite the bullet and carry
on
oh nice nice hallway here
i can't even use
okay my team is doing big things right
now
and by that i mean like not me them
they're they're leading the charge i
love this team
you got james in the chat saying this
map ain't even legit
any armor i don't have enough money
this guy's loading up on goodies
where is it oh good i was like where's
the loadout friendly loadout drop on the
way
all right i think i made one with the
ppsh yeah so i'll just use it for your
sake
i only have like one attachment on it
but check it out guys here it is
it is actually in the game my station
identified
omari in the chat says when will the new
map be here it is live now
you can play this right now uh it's hard
to get in kind of because the servers
are a little goofy but
enemy soldier
but this is what's going on right now uh
verdansk was nuked
after that happened we got to play
we got to play rebirth island where we
were able to
launch the nuke that hit verdance that
was pretty cool
once that happens we time travel back
into the 1980s
and here we are now playing verdansk in
1984.
it's empty here guys it's empty
is he alone i should have pushed
i'm not okay my team's here to back me
up i'm not a good pusher alone
he's right here oh let me get out of the
way
as long as i'm close to a teammate i'm
fine they're the ones carrying me
so big shout out to them big shout out
to them
like all four of us are still alive and
it's not my fault or it's not because of
me
uh i hope you guys are enjoying the
stream this has been a crazy
like 48 hours some people would say
underwhelming
but the point is we now have movement
for dancing
on four that's the new map for dance for
reals for dance materials
for dance uh you know 2021 got nuked
this is it now this is it this is the
permanent replacement
of verdansk
the music is kicking in hear that
yes more people in the chat saying
finally and i'm finally in okay
enemy precision airstrike take cover my
stupid laser here let me revive my homie
first
trophy system deploy your strong boss
that you're making
ghosts and price the homies forever
did you get them
did you get them closing in relocating
the safe zone
two teams left six people guys it's
looking
possible okay i gotta get out of here
though before the smoke
uh you've got gas moving in kills me
safe zone's far off let's get moving
there's a crown over there okay this
looks like the last group of guys
growing grenades
that's a win yeah we did it we got a
stream
victory we we did it oh they did it
i helped whatever i helped him yeah we
did it though
all right
good game man these guys i gotta
befriend these guys
shout out to them they're the ones who
made this possible
yeah spam dubs in the chat that was
great
that guy i think he had the most kills
that guy sells blood on his face
polarizing
gg all right thanks guys
it's been a while not gonna lie it's
hard to uh stream
try to try to look around interact with
chat
like i'm already that's why i the team
look i got two kills
not bad though not bad look at that all
right let's go at it again
show you guys what it looks like to play
this event hopefully more of you guys
are getting in
yourselves um
and and and playing this for yourselves
but that's what it looks like we are
officially in
dance 1984 but the only way to get there
is to play this rebirth mode first
soon i'm sure like after tomorrow it'll
be you know romance 84 will be the
permanent replacement but right now
if you're playing this event you get to
play both you get to nuke the old
verdansk
time travel back to 1984 and play 1984
for dansk
yes more people in chat they're saying
they're
oh yeah okay i'm getting word from aaron
sampson that once this event
uh ends possibly around one or
um we might see just the full map
integration we won't need to play this
uh
rebirth part anymore let me ask him
aaron are you available for
a game are you free
that's okay that's current i mean uh
yeah that's the only game mode i'm
seeing aaron's telling me that i don't
he's not sure we can join up and play
for dance 84 together but i think it
might be possible
okay cool cool uh he's going to see if
he's available to join
shout out to aaron sampson gamespot's
very own
uh so i'll wait for him here uh how's it
going for you guys in chat are you
more people getting in yeah okay aaron
is in my party
let's see let's do the whole thing let's
do the event from the start for those of
you just joining
this is part two of the destruction of
verdansk the official
event has rolled out today it should be
over
uh soon uh i think like within the next
hour
aaron what was it from 12 to two just
like yesterday
oh okay
uh for those of you who haven't seen it
let's check it out
here we go
going this way
more people are are saying they're stuck
in the queue my heart goes out to you
guys hopefully i mean
yesterday i was stuck in the queue live
on stream for 30 minutes so i know that
i know the struggle
keep trying it help for me to uh like
close the game you know on your on your
playstation close the app entirely and
then come back
i hate to give uh you know
i don't want to give you bad advice but
i'm just saying that's what worked for
me
so uh good luck keep trying because
everyone's got to be able to that'd be
really shallow you know
not shallow it sucks
i know that's possible but anyway here's
the event
um it starts on rebirth island yesterday
we had rebirth island but today it's a
different game
where you get one of those uh tablets
you have to hang on to it because it's
got the nuclear codes
and if you can survive with that little
tablet with the nuclear launch codes
your team wins they punch in the new
codes for dansk
2021 this is how it uh this is however
dance gets new
the events take place on rebirth island
then once that happens
no matter what you get to see no matter
what you get to experience
the new map but you launch the nukes
from here
and then you go on to play virginia
beginning of part two that's what's
right now breaking for dansk is reaching
critical mass
we need to clear all enemies and gather
valuable intel before it's over right
here all right soldiers this is it three
just
aaron was able to join my lobby this is
great we got two
david so many dudes
but you start with your loadout check it
out it's a different you know it's a
different setup this time you hot drop
with all your stuff
you need armor but um soon
the uh the zombies will start to take
over for dancing you'll hear it
on the screen you'll see you'll see
you'll hear it in your ear and you'll
see
this stuff because what's going on over
dance right now is that it's getting
overrun but we're here in rebirth island
on the other side of the scene activate
the tactical
tactical nuke device deploying soon okay
what that means
you'll see what that means in just a
moment that little tablet i talked about
yes more people in the chat saying they
got in kenneth just got in woohoo
oh snap there he's got the dual psychos
soy cops
and he sprayed me i think
okay in 20 seconds we're gonna have to
oh [ __ ]
20 seconds we're gonna have to go find
that tablet we need a nuke for dansk
if you can hang on to that tablet thingy
for you know i think it's like two
minutes or so
yo eric i'm hearing eric
practical oh cool okay eric is telling
me that the playlist
may have updated and we can just play
verdansk84 we don't have to play this
whole event
uh this event is a limited time thing so
i think we'll play it out one last time
here with aaron sampson
and if we've got time left on stream
i'll just uh continue to play vergansk84
because it's
just now we've learned that the nuclear
device the tablet is right here so if
you can get your hands on it and hang on
to it
you will personally be responsible for
new convergence
all right no matter what though i mean
even if you aren't the ones
holding the tablet and actually you know
calling in the nuke you get to see what
happens so it's good for everyone
i do want to win though that'd be really
nice we got close in one match we were
hanging on to the nuke tablet
but then i got killed you know it's a
hot mess right now everyone wants the
tablet everyone wants to meet for dansk
everyone wants to win looks like
oh interesting eric oh eric is letting
me know that
even if um we have the tablet in our
hands and we're down but not dead we can
still call in the nuke and win
so that's interesting where am i getting
i think it might help to back out reset
uh that's what helped us yesterday
okay eric tay is in my ear telling me to
tell you
to back out if you're in the server
queue like back out and try again
oh man i cut down i fail help help
ah
okay eric is also telling me uh this is
for you kevin in the chat if um
if you do back out you run the risk of
not being able to play this rebirth
event
currently if you back out the new
playlist may have updated and you may
only be able to play verdan's game
before
uh just a heads up um
yeah best of luck kevin um keep us
updated everyone keep us updated on
what's going on we uh
yeah you know and thanks for sticking
around it's this is the only way people
are
able to see this event so far is by
watching streams like this so we
appreciate you
being here and hope you're having some
fun i know it's hard to get
you know have some fun when you're stuck
but show some love let us know how we're
doing
and if i haven't said it drop the thumb
look at that 95 96 we're gonna see what
happens any moment now
although i don't think it'll be us
because yeah we're too far away
it happened okay tactical nuke device
ready for activation
enemy has the device enemy's enemy is
gonna launch something
ready for activation where the hell am i
going
phelps welcome back from yesterday hey
how's it going he asked any thoughts on
the event
i'm having fun with it but i'm really
upset that a lot of people can't get in
um
it's kind of a fun way to switch over
from season two to season three and to
finally
finally get some changes to her dance um
but i mean i'm having fun i just wish
everyone can uh get in
you know this is a small window of time
i'm no good with this sniper rifle but
what am i reloading this for already oh
this was used that's why
this was used device activated
wait give us a chance
okay what you had to do i'm gonna back
out you guys
let you check out what happens enjoy
eight two two
six
nothing more we can do it's over
all right guys we got separated and
booted out but that's okay because this
is new
i think the playlist updated and it
pushed me back out to this
the hunt for adler look at this rescue
adler stitch is holding adler in a
undisclosed location in verdansk uh i
think it's like underground somewhere
gather intel to pinpoint his position
and rescue him all right
get some challenges and rewards look at
that little beeper charm
you got a new skin and then uh looks
like you get a uh a
new uh skin for adler too or who is that
let's see
complete either the cold war or war zone
set of challenges to unlock this
exclusive
tortured and rescue aller adler skin
so that is adler he's looking rough
and the battle pass is here in full
effect
look at that oh this is the event this
is not the battle pass this is uh all
the intel cool so there's a small
the hunt for adler event seems to have
kicked off right at one o'clock-ish
or so and these are the prizes you can
get
for finding all the intel and completing
missions
let's see here to get this calling card
you have to
kill 25 enemies on a kill streak using
the assassin per okay so
not impossible stuff here good to see
looks like aaron is back in my party
what's up aaron
start at the hospital hmm i think okay i
think now i want to jump into the
in fact yeah see look it's gone the
event is officially gone the
destruction of vergansk is no longer a
playlist
it is currently only battle royale in
verdansk84
so me and aaron let's do some duos and
check it out
okay looks like there's a playlist
update that i will have to
hang back and download kenneth the event
uh officially just ended i think um
you can play verdance84 now but as far
as the rebirth nuke thing that's gone
oh snap eric tay in the party
for dance um well i'm on i'm on discord
with the two of these guys
do you guys want to play regular battle
royale or do you want to try trio's uh
the
the resurgence mode where we get
respawns
yeah okay verdansk resp for dance
resurgence trio it's quite the mouthful
let's do it this is
yeah this is probably a better way for
you guys to see more of the map
you know when you die you come back good
for stream
all right thank you guys all for being
here and chatting with us in the
comments in youtube i think we're on uh
the trailers channel youtube trailer our
gamespot trailers and game spot it's
main page thank you for being here
wherever you're watching thank you for
joining us i hope you can get in
soon yourself uh travis asks what i'm
playing on i'm playing on ps5 right now
all right it's loading but we got in i
think let's see here
75 ping 90 ping i might back out and try
again you guys
um but you'll come you'll be with me
aaron and eric let me just try to
refresh this this thing
i may have uh eric's asking me if he's
if i've seen the
cinematic cut scene oh no i'm getting
boo i'm getting put into the game now
maybe eric i will be seeing it in a
moment
kevin kevin is going on 80 minutes of
waiting i hope you've tried backing out
man i think it'll really help
just kind of refresh everything can we
hear today no he's currently on discord
with me
yes shout out to tay warm-up's done
time to kick this off this is for dance
g84 and well
check out the new intro guys
come on man i was trying to forget lil
tay
the cut scene aaron just uh it started
the game it was a small cut scene it was
the new plane mode
like we're in helicopters instead of the
big plane and we are now playing
the match uh eric i'm just gonna jump
out let's
try to uh maybe hit up the train station
heading this way
oh man aaron got aaron sampson got
kicked from our game now it's just it's
we can back out uh but what do you think
eric taylor should we show you back out
and see if we can
reclaim our errand
please engage your targets um
erin what's the screen look like for you
now are you just back in the regular old
lobby thing
okay eric and i are going to try to give
this a shot you guys without aaron
sampson
um and uh we'll look around we'll check
out the new
verdansk 84. you're losing ground
and chat i think you're right you guys
um every ground pickup has been
only black ops weapons
here in boxes
we should have for the sake son yeah
just a bunch of
black ops weapons wish us luck
oh kevin has tried backing out multiple
times damn it kevin
damn it i was i was rooting for you
um have you tried like kevin have you
tried like closing the game straight up
like entirely
uh that helped me yesterday but
um i don't know i'm not sure
this is new i think the train station
wasn't always this open was it
might be tripping but anyway the gas is
getting to us i gotta return to eric k
before i die
and armor up what am i doing
did they add fov sliders slider no
that's a good question i don't think so
it's a different engine than cold war so
it shouldn't
shouldn't be
look
no no fov slider
that if that'd be cool you know people
are always asking for a
uh next-gen next-gen version of
warzone that'd be cool but i don't think
it's in the works for a while
so do i have many glider things what are
glider things chat
kevin did restart kevin i'm so sorry
hey a loadout oh eric painted all right
cool cool cool
this will be a way to figure out if uh
modern warfare weapons are
successfully implemented into this i'm
sure they are but they're just not on
the ground
yeah look my fennec is here i can pick
all this stuff in fact
yeah why don't the a 94 and the old as
val let's
do it it's been a while
anyway into getting the discord audio
onto the stream nah not this time i'm
afraid we're all uh
we're all situated here and i think that
shuffle would kind of mess things up
maybe but
uh if you all want that if y'all want
eric tay you gotta let him know
he he he's here with me today but yeah
player only no voice there he is
and he is fighting people on the roof
i see him let me post up on this rock
oh they're gonna get hit with the smoke
soon
mark the target hmm can i do single
shots
kind of pick at him
new guy yeah
we're gonna hit with the smoke too i'm
gonna push forward to this little
building right here
i'm sure we will have more engagements
later long in the chat says
love tay big fan that's classic right
there classic game spot flying
right here
oh box enemies in the area
dead silence hey bad guys coming up oh
no they're leaving
slot the bastard okay i'm gonna go
upstairs and see if i can peek at the
bounty from the second floor maybe pick
at him a little bit enemy uav
over here great we got uav on us
nope he's inside this building oh shoot
okay he's across the street uh i i want
a ping but i'm gonna get hit
got movement he definitely saw me from
the second floor so i'm gonna maybe
flank around over here
if he's got a sniper he's not ready for
close he doesn't want this close range
combat smoke
i had a single fire on single shot
what up travis all the way from new
hampshire hey hello from california
mckenzie says they announced a next-gen
version of warzone on twitter
i haven't seen that i mean we'll check
it out later
um that'd be cool now
we died but we can move on and see if
aaron is able to join us this time
let me try to send him an invite
aaron it's doing the oh okay aaron is
currently in the game he will
join us momentarily
okay
okay i'm hearing from eric taylor he's
going to quickly record a cut scene
for the gamespot youtube page
it says you're not joinable either
there's like a lock where i can't join
your game
oh yeah party quick invite
it's not you're not on this list this
time aaron you're not
on the quick invite list
this is so annoying
people in the chat calling me out damn
you're a bot you know
that's okay i admittedly i openly and
admittedly say i'm not the best warzone
player my kd in warzone is like
i think like just under one um
but today was the point the point of
today was to
check out for dansk84 and i want to do
it with
aaron sampson but he does not oh
okay um eric i'm going to jump into
aaron's party
oh no no wait hold on did it cut
off your gameplay eric
invites a party okay let's see if we get
the boys back together
yeah i invited him i invited eric let's
see if we can um
have him join our party this is a cool
new little walking screen though
we are cross-playing here eric uh our
aaron is on uh xbox xbox series x and
i'm on ps5
yeah i invited him
there we go all right
she's sorry dude i forgot about that
oh eric uh for chat eric is talking
about yeah
it's not old but i think it might have
launched today the uh
a short cinematic cut scene of adler
being tortured by stitch
and they show him like deep underground
of the verdance map
um
um wraith um i did see a trailer with
her but i don't know if it was
today or like from before
uh what's new like uh like cold war
stuff
oh yeah we'll try to get there sometimes
the map doesn't allow um
i'm talking with eric tay and eric
sampson and we want to figure out how to
show you guys the new points of interest
on the map there's quite a few
uh we have to land there obviously but
sometimes the map
is uh is it's not a safe zone to land in
hopefully it is this time
okay waiting um i'm hearing from aaron
sampson who was uh
says let's give it another minute
because he is now the party leader
trying to get a game going but in
another minute if it doesn't work we'll
back out and try on the
ps5 side of things thanks guys for
sticking around
chatting with us hanging out with us
today big day
big day finally can talk about a lot of
stuff
the new verdansk 85 map our verdance 84
map
the rebirth event
kevin from chat is finally in yes
okay we're going to try again going back
into
using me as the party leader here um
leave lobbying party i'll quick invite
everyone who i can and then let's get
into a game
aaron are you able to join my party it's
not letting me
add you again
great
we're both here all right all of us are
here great
maybe i'll try um regular battle royale
it's fine
all right guys thanks for your patience
let's see if we can get into a game
good luck big shout out to kevin who's
been trying all morning
sounds like he's finally in
um aaron is telling me on his side of
things on the xbox servers things might
be a little
a little harder to get into please be
patient
um but now that i'm the host of the ps5
lobby version here it looks like
it looks like yeah waiting loading level
looks good looks good
good point aaron is bringing up that we
should drop at the damn it has been
in this update it has changed so i
definitely want you guys to see it
jaden in the chat is also in yes good
stuff you guys
okay keep saying like loading level
looking for players
let's just give it another moment here
now of course it's cracking up
yeah it's just searching searching for a
uh searching for a match at 2014
all right wish us luck
kevin in the chat he's back at it he
says yeah my xbox server is still not
working
but my playstation version is now all
right
kevin maybe if you were downloading all
these updates maybe that's why you
couldn't get in earlier
straight pulling pulling uh your
internet a lot there
but anyway you can get in framed
we got apps uh
pc servers are down man and they share i
believe
if i'm not mistaken they might share
xbox and pc servers together because
you can't turn off cross play when
you're on uh
i think xbox so it might be kind of
fudging up right now
okay okey doke
um eric you and i let's try duos aaron
sampson is on the horn and he says he's
going to try to back out maybe
uh it's not working with him in the
lobby on the xbox side of things so
looks like this is happening to a lot of
people in chat so i mean i appreciate
you guys patience because this is
it seems to be happening to us all let's
try um
just go in the the playstation route
here see if that works
patrick patrick in the chat is asking
some big questions
wait so that they did they nuke for
dansk is this the new map
yes uh it's a good time to talk about it
while we wait um
yesterday the destruction of verdansk
event part one
happened you got to play on verdansk it
was taken over by zombies
so they had a nougat there was no way to
exfil
and uh today is the destruction of
verdance part two which already happened
earlier today
on this stream from rebirth island you
you were the one calling in the nukes to
drop on verdansk
like they showed both sides of the story
and after that happened
you were able to finally play the new
map which is
verdansk84 so it's a 1984 version of
verdansk and it is the permanent
replacement for
warzone and we're trying to get in i'm
trying to show you
but apparently we're having a lot of
server issues not just
us everyone in chat is still
still struggling um eric tay are you on
playstation network
oh no you are i was just wondering if
you're on playstation network
eric then we can i can um what's it
called i can turn off cross play maybe
just try to get in
okay maybe i'll give that a go uh so
eric and
eric and i can have a chance at getting
into some more
uh um quieter lobbies here let's see if
that'll work
[Music]
okay i can't turn off cross play while
we're in a party together so i'm going
to back out eric and then i'll reinvite
you
he already left okay
dang it i have to back out to do that
rats
okay no problem cross play disabled now
i will
invite eric tate
and see if we can get into a playstation
lobby
got some more words from chat that
playstation
i'm sorry pc is not working currently as
well
man yeah maybe too many people are
probably playing right now
wish us luck you guys we're gonna try
for
we're gonna try this out with just the
playstation servers
hello chica rob in the chat on the
gamespot trailers channel what's up how
you guys doing
a lot of waiting here
a lot of people are still stuck in the
queue they can't even make it to this
point that
stinks man yesterday somehow it was
smoother and that was day one
um
man even on the playstation side of
things it's not looking good it's a
little
little better 73 better than 120 but
oh went up to 90.
yeah apparently this is a big problem
all across
yeah people it's uh it's not looking
good we're saying uh
it's crowded in here guys
nice
a few more times of this and then i'll
i might try the cross play servers after
this
ah i'm hearing from aaron over on the
xbox side of things that he got into a
match but then he got kicked out it's
rough for everyone hey shout out to hey
we have some viewers from scotland hey
how's it going yeah a lot of people are
waiting forever glad we're not alone on
this i mean
it's hard to be i mean it's easy to be
mad at it but like we're all here kind
of hanging out together that's nice at
least
she got robbed in the chat showing love
let me see what i've upgraded
finally finished out the mac 10 i think
oh just with uh skins
what's your guys's loadout in uh in
warzone let me know in the chat i mean
right now i was telling the chat earlier
that i have a very
meta load out here the hot the hot guns
at the moment
but uh i also got some really goofy
classes that i like to play around with
and uh there's from like all sorts of
weapons all sorts of perks just trying
to have some fun
and unlock you know more attachments for
these guns but
you know for stream i think i might keep
it keep it meta
more people hey some people are saying
uh one person said it works and they got
in all right cool cool cool
alex ramirez i did wait in the queue
this morning a little bit for the event
not as long as yesterday this has been
the longest part of waiting look at that
we got a playlist update i think
so let me try backing out with eric
and see um try this here
a little little refresher here i'm still
joined by eric tay
do some duo's no cross play just to give
it one more shot that doesn't work again
i'll open it up
hmm single shot soy cough and the car
98 kilo and mac
10 all right
the as val and the car 98 this is some
nice variety a lot of you guys like the
car 98 though huh i am no good with that
gun i am no
i am ass with uh most snipers and
marksman rifles
all right i will enable cross play
hopefully it just works i have a wider
net of games to join so i'm going to try
that
the growl i i love the kilo that was the
very first gun i got gold like it's one
of the first guns you unlock in modern
warfare so i just used it all the way
i love that gun and then it became like
the hot gun for a while remember that
before the growl came
yeah a lot of people are going through
the same thing well
that leaves us just hanging out for
anyone who has just joined
if you want a refresher on the story let
me know the event is officially over and
we are playing
verdansk84 we're trying to
uh but a lot happened in the last two
days so if you got questions let me know
kevin who finally got on says i can't
join a damn
lobby us either man we are stuck
we are stuck but hey why don't i talk
about some of the new points of interest
for
verdansk84 uh for those of you who
haven't got to experience it or
experience it much there were a lot of
updates a lot was left the same a lot of
the familiar big areas were the same
they're just an 80s version of it now so
we've got
stadium which is about halfway built the
airport doesn't have a big crater right
in the middle of it so
it is now a two two story functional
building
we also have new points of interest from
returning maps
like if you guys remember black ops 2
and the multiplayer map standoff
that map has been added into warzone
it's awesome
we haven't been able to see it yet
because it's always been out of the zone
of uh
parachuting or you know dropping in but
also another zone that has returned from
an old black ops game is summit
if you guys remember the summit map from
black ops 1
that map it was a snowy map but they
they they added that map into
verdansk84 and it is it's not snowy
but some updates were made too like the
gondolas the
the the gondolas are functional now
that's fun
uh new bigger points of interest include
the duga which is that
big like net looking array it's like a
major antenna it's like right in the
middle of the map
it was featured in the cold war campaign
that area
has been added into warzone they added a
bunch of
new smaller buildings downtown is not
fully constructed yet or it is
constructed but there are a lot less
skyscrapers it is less
dense and i would love to show you guys
all this but we're still
struggling here on the trying to get
into a game
um but once we do i want to give you
guys you know a look around and
show you what's new it also just looks
greener like um
her dance wasn't always so you know
muted
brown kind of poopy color it was a lot
nicer in the 80s and that's
the permanent this whole map is a
permanent replacement
to the oliver dance so we're not going
to see the old verdance
anymore anytime soon anyway from what we
hear
this is the permanent replacement until
something new comes along
and we're just trying to play it guys
we're just trying to get into a game
it's not working so we're stuck here i
wish you guys can
see
okay aaron simpson is going to try to
refresh his his setup
yes john summit summit is now a part of
war zone also uh the dam
isn't a damn structure there is a like
there is now just just a bridge like if
you if you google like bixby bridge it's
one of those really high bridges
uh it's like that so there is still like
a slope for water and stuff to come down
but it is not a dam structure
it is just a big bridge
you guys i think it's happening okay
phelps in the chat said after a playlist
update i get matches normally
that's what happened to me too we got a
playlist update but then we got stuck
for a while so
hopefully this is
fetching online okay aaron on the xbox
side of things said he backed out and
now he's getting the fetching
online profile screen man
we got a countdown on the top of the
screen for a sec that said game starting
in five four and then it went back to
searching for a match
jeez
well we're all in the same boat
appreciate you guys being here
um just gonna try to stick it out this
is so strange and annoying
it's not strange it's a very busy day
for these servers so
please remain patient
all right let me go back to my um my
loadouts maybe i can build something
while we're waiting
uh we noticed something also um in in
verdansk 84
you aren't able like all the ground loot
is um
is not is all cold war weapons there are
no modern warfare weapons on the ground
which you know
narratively makes sense but it's kind of
weird you can't pick up you know
guns we're familiar using
i really like my class here i think i'm
just going to stick with this let me
double check um
i did want to switch this over to
heartbeat sensor
and tune up i might use instead of tune
up i might use
amp to swip switch weapons faster maybe
brutal fox in the chat is being so
optimistic he's like maybe he'll get a
match in by sundown
or by sunset this is nuts
this is ridiculous i'm gonna back out
one more time just see if
we can refresh here just kind of have
another
hmm another breather here we go
battle royale duos
it's a good idea aaron aaron samson on
the on the chat he's suggesting maybe
plunder maybe plunder is less busy and
we can still
experience the new map which uh it's a
good idea i'm gonna check it out if
if this ping goes way up i'm gonna back
out and try plunder i just want you guys
to see the map
okay i'm hearing from aaron sampson that
the plunder lobby is
is possible here so i'm going to take
his is accept his invite and see if we
can get into a game
eric tay i'm not sure if you are around
and heard that but we are in
aaron's lobby
this is working this is looking good the
point was to show off the map you guys
so like um
this is this is definitely better than
nothing
just plunder i'm not
it's not br but it is but you know
plunder version
let's check it out hopefully it works
final countdown at the top three two one
all right all right
we got in i can't believe it
and yeah we get to respawn so if i die
we can show you more of the map
z kizzle in the chat says man are you
you're just fine with it being the same
man playing again especially when i
heard about the new event i'm
super disappointed i feel your pain yeah
it is it
essentially it's a reskin here's the dam
by the way um
and there's summit up there
but yeah i understand i mean it's more
of a change than anything it's not
look at this that's nice oh it's kind of
hard you cannot this is
very a very vulnerable spot
all right i see enemy soldiers i see you
on top of the satellite aaron
oh aaron aaron is saying from where he's
at up here don't need me bro he can see
you're going to the war zone that's
here we go plunder time
the textures didn't load in from my
man's face that was pretty scary
there he goes it's fine now so that's
the new intro whether you're in vr
or plunder that's the new opening you
get helicopters now
so ladies the job's simple secure more
cash than the enemy
oh that's what you mean aaron there's
the big mushroom cloud
of nuke we got nuked back into the 80s
remember aaron and i made a joke about
that
we were like aaron says that's not how
nuclear weapons work
but it's a narrative it's a narrative
storytelling event
uh aaron is that you orange yeah i'll go
i'll follow you to the damn
roger mark there's the new dam and
behind it is what i want to get to
it's the summit map in fact i might do
the old sideways thing here
there's cory down below which is now the
salt mines pretty much the same setup
only every door is unlocked and the
ground doesn't dip into all these holes
it's now these holes are filled with
salt line so that's cool that's new
there's the old hanger area over here or
whatever it's called it is uh
yeah outside of the military base
so let's go explore
aaron you made it there fast i think i
jumped too late or i didn't launch my
parachute in time
where's the nearest vehicle hell yeah
mark is a vehicle hillary uav over here
this structure over here is not even
around
stupid trees secure that position
overall looks good
chad is saying but kind of campy go to
standoff i went the wrong way for
standoff i'm sorry we want to show you
some at first landed with my loadout
again interesting
is that the new way is that is that what
this is
all right time to make our way to summit
aaron died oh no
is there a whole team there aaron
oh yeah there are responses
okay if you're interested uh we did get
in but we're using we're playing plumber
i just really wanted to show you guys
the map so this may be the only way to
do it for a while
sunny unsnowy version of gold black ops
[Applause]
summit
look at it look at it let me see if i
can
find some armor here or some money okay
oh
no where is this guy shooting me
camping sure oh no he was just up top
he got me fairy square jordy not the
jordy right
jordy is asking in the chat bro how are
you playing
um aaron's brilliant idea
he said let's try a plunder map so we're
playing plunder
um so maybe that'll work for you try it
out try it out
try it out before it gets way too hot
okay aaron is uh okay i want to try to
check out the summit area
i'm going in i might die again
but there it is and the gondolas are
functional this is
nuts there's someone in there [ __ ] i'm
toast
maybe
someone's right above me up here
i don't think he knows i'm here actually
okay trying to just trying to get into
the summit now y'all
a lot of doors here okay
enemy uav overhead
next objective located
friendly uav overhead
oh hostile dropping into the area he's
telling me that uh
reports are indicating uh from charlie
intel that
there may be a newer version of warzone
coming to the current console
where did you finish it
okay eric taylor is also telling me that
he got into a solo match
regular
i'm going all the way down i don't want
to go this far down
i can use the armor that's good so good
luck to all you guys trying to get in
there
um appreciate your patience
it's annoying to do this like on live
you know just kind of waiting
but we got into a match finally so i
hope you're enjoying what you're seeing
oh no taking effective fire don't worry
you'll survive one guy in the chat says
i can't even get into
ran out of bullets huh
robert robert in the chat is just asking
how my day is going
robert it's been a crazy day
uh but thank you for asking this is a
lot going on right now
a lot of uh technical issues are are
popping up but we finally got into a
match i think sorry these are going good
oh just uh aaron's looking for the
airport if you
see here
heading there over here are there plague
zones
here i'll ping the airport if you can
make it there via car or something hey
the train is still here
yeah brutal fox noticed that guy who was
killing me he just i'm driving he's just
here to ruins everyone's day
well i mean plunder is always used for
this kind of stuff like exploration and
b-roll but i feel bad for people who
actually just want to play plunder
because i'm you know i'm doing that
right now i'm not really
playing i just want to show you guys the
map that was the the point of this
stream
the event and the new map so i want us
to all look around
but yeah like i'm not collecting the
money right now
hey aaron's got a whip
let's go wait for me
all right
there's the airport control tower
apparently
the new airport is a good way to fight
[Music]
check out what's up here wow
this is nice very nice
friendly uav overhead pretty much the
same
uh in terms of structure but you know
it's got that 80s look
a lot more carpet things are a little
more colorful
crap aaron got the the advanced uav
well it's good we can we can safely
check out this area
well without all the smoke
oh got the balloon yeah sure why not
wait what the hell oh that takes through
all right
i want to get to the second floor of
this airport that's where that's where
the new
uh points of interest are high caliber
here
cancel my live caliber here okay aaron
says go to where he is
here we go down the stairs
nice okay for those of you asking yeah
for this new map we're not seeing
oh someone just pulled up we're not
seeing
going this way modern warfare guns on
the ground so much anymore
it's all cold war wait uh let me go back
to your opinion aaron
here we go hey you just worked your way
up here with this huh
friendly uav overhead look at that well
this was here this part was just
aaron
oh aaron is showing off the the sight
line there we go this is what they
showed off in like our little
presentation
this is a good area to like post up and
possibly fight people who are
you know at the airport control tower
thank you aaron for pointing that out
maybe enemy uav overhead i'm gonna cross
over and see if i can drop this balloon
thing i got some money on me so
quick dub might be nice enemy soldier
ain't coming
will it break through this window oh
aaron says you can get to the roof okay
from where you're standing aaron
is there a ladder or something i see
movement
wait aaron where'd you go oh you're
behind
oh repel thing okay cool excellent
i know chat the hole in the airport is
not there uh it hasn't happened yet
this is a fully functional two-story
building so
it's nice to see drop your cash
launch launch
oh man we have two other members of our
team they're so far away
the planes in the air aaron oh they're
dropping off
things
oh oh right we're playing we're playing
plunder
i'm
okay so look check it out we can be on
the roof the entire roof of there
i think only part of it was accessible
last time aaron is pinging
yeah there are airplanes like they're
not destroyed
oh there's one yeah you could go through
that one before look at this guy way
over here look at this dude
mark the target uh but aaron ping the
point of interest over there that's new
it's called like the uh
old oil rig or something like that
is that where standoff is
contact
someone's poking at me over there not
nice
yeah chat let us know uh aaron and i are
sort of just exploring plunder is a
great way to do that but let us know if
uh what areas you want to see
we checked out summit already uh
standoff is here somewhere the old black
ops 2 map
standoff is a part of warzone now maybe
that would be cool the gulag is also
modeled after
enemy soldier right now i'm currently
walking to where aaron paint it's like
this new
like run down oil rig instead before it
was just like
nothing and i think the end of the
tunnel but now there's a little
place to hide but dudes are
over there it's hot target right here
enemy soldier ain't coming
yeah we can check out corey hey aaron
why don't i'll get this little
atv and maybe we can just drive around
looks like some people are huh
yeah aaron says our teammates probably
hit us here
i'll drive by this little place real
quick
wasn't there before
so yeah just just another place to hide
there not bad
friendly positions
port prison farmland see they're all
labeled the same array
that's new uh we landed there earlier
today
factory the airport or the airplane
factory moving
aaron would you paint it
yo you want your own car cory okay if
you want your own car
there it is all right i woke up we're
going to the new quarry oh there's some
smoke on that
welcome to the chat i hope you're able
to play
oh there's a dude over there to my right
i'm gonna be here left yep
the dam is now just a bridge we start we
showed that off a little earlier
uh aaron do you chad is asking if if you
remember
if hospital has changed
yeah if they didn't mention it i'm sure
and it's at its core it's still the same
but it might
you know have carpet
some some 80s about it superstore
yeah we got new back that's what's going
on
that's too too big of a hill here we go
black ops
we are making our way to the quarry
right now we've got a little
80s facelift you know and i'll show you
what it looks like
although let me know and chat uh do you
guys like cory i
usually never land there because i don't
know i have bad luck
in general you see instead of the
craters these
salt mines have been filled up it is now
called like the salt mines or something
like that
it's all mine hell yeah
look at this big dumb truck
this is a new area these there are less
trains
to hide behind oh okay nevermind
there's the nuke in the background
beautiful
oh yeah aaron i want to see uh if we can
find standoff i thought it was near the
gulag i don't know
where it is lumber farmland
heading there i thought it was
uh where were you pinged yeah i thought
so too okay let's check out this area
outside of the prison
and see if standoff is there if memory
serves from what we saw from the
presentation it is there so
you know let's explore
ah man more people in the chat are like
i just i just turned it off it took too
long
i feel free man took us a while to get
into this match
uh here's the duga array and the
foreground over here
that's cool you can hide behind it and
you can fight on top of it and land
there too
but it is uh where are we yeah it's on
the
east northeast
a bunch of lighting over there that i
never noticed before i could just go
straight south
enemy attack shuffle incoming almost out
of time
wait oh before no i think we're okay
i think a lot of people are exploring
because somehow i'm winning plunder look
at the bottom right there
oh no
being shot at jerks
yeah look at the stadium is halfway
built and the train station is not
a thing
downtown is half of what it normally is
no skyscrapers just one tall building
right now we're trying to make our way
over to yeah r.i.p modern warfare says
chat
um yeah straight up except
it is it is in name only that this is
like a
modern warfare game i think uh not even
they just call it call of duty warzone
they always have but
uh same engine i think that's about it
right aaron is saying uh swimming still
doesn't look possible
you know new engineering
you invaded the enemy track good work
no this is just like the report let me
go back
closer to the gulag i swore that they
talked about it
right here i might have misspoke but
standoff from black ops 2 has made his
way into war zone
so i'm trying to find it and it's not
late of course look at this
park promenade hills hospital superstore
factory is new it's a small airport
factory that's new
the array is new we drove by that
assault mine is new recon intel secured
solid work
man i really thought it was here i
pictured it here i swear the
bridges show us
chad is saying just restart if you can't
get in that's the best advice i've given
all day
and it seems to be working for some
people so
your own risk back out close the game
restart
actually focus here like this is uh
vacant
there's port farmland
lumber i'm looking for standoff
um storage town
military base it's all mine
yeah they're not they're not giving us
uh any clues to where it is that's a
little annoying but
i hope you guys are enjoying our little
tour of uh
gasket this part looks i'm not even
alive it's exactly the same
silver that's a lot of money
i accidentally got six plays sixth place
standoff is in the gulag whole lot of
red that's for sure when you're playing
regular br and you die you go to the new
gulag
but they told us that it was part it was
going to be a 6v6 map
and that it was incorporated into
warzone so i'm looking for
uh eric and aaron do you know how much
time we have left i just realized that
it is two o'clock
hmm
sounds good okay we are going to try one
more match of uh
regular br here
oh that's all right um and then we will
call it there you guys
battle royale let me see if i can get
aaron into our potty
our party here or maybe aaron you can
invite me i can't
join you right now
okay whole lot of red says can you make
your mic volume maybe a bit louder
um yes i can if um
yeah i'll turn up just a little bit
appreciate that
oh man
okay i'm gonna play one more match you
guys probably with a full
random squad here so let's see hopefully
i can get in
and then we'll call it there i'll make
room for you guys to get in
eric yep it is uh eric in the chat says
five o'clock on the east coast it is
all right i'm hearing from aaron sampson
who um
it's not looking good for him he got a
maintenance screen and it says
estimated time to get back in just 20
minutes so we're going to see if i can
get into a regular random match
with uh randos no party hopefully
that'll help speed things up and then
we'll call it there
if you've been here the whole time just
trying to get in
thanks for tuning in i know it's been a
hard day on the servers and for
us but we appreciate you here
if you're having any fun at all drop a
like
aren't the servers down chat yeah it
might might just be doing some
maintenance right now
um aaron tells me on his side of things
he's playing on xbox
that he can't get in because they're
doing maintenance somehow i'm still here
but we're looking for a game at 72 ping
so
eric n in the chat says 20 minutes for
me too yeah i probably will get kicked
out at this point look at this 90 ping
phelps asks thoughts on the event i
thought it was
i thought the event itself was cool it
was um
it was okay um i wish would have been
cool if it were all one day but you know
i can't
i understand that everyone can't make it
in one day but the servers were the
crappiest part like this is um it's
rough people just want to play
it's filling up and i get it you know
like millions of literally millions of
people want to play
and uh so i'm not trying to dump on the
activision servers but it's a hard day
for everyone in a lot of instances
overall though the actual narrative the
actual story and the event was fun
it just was hard to get into
the watchers is telling me it might put
you into a game but then you'll get
kicked out
for dance 84 you are tricky themed
wish me luck what did i unlock i hate
these green squares so i always try to
clear them out you know
as you can see i don't use the ffar very
much
trying to it's one of the fastest
fire rates of any ar that's key
phelps says let's just play modern
warfare multiplayer
i would i would love that
see here what do i unlock here oh
[Music]
the machete okay cuckoo
checking in with um
here
okay got into a lobby let's see if that
means anything i've seen this happen
before and then it just you know
doesn't work
yeah see it back me up oh loading level
we shall see
wish me luck wish me luck
wow i made it this far you guys all
right whole lot of red i feel for you
man
or i'm mad that you still need to play
war zone again
oh
get yourself sorted we'll be
but we got it this will probably be my
last match
so let's go out and blaze of glory
the street sweeper chat noticed
something
and i think it's true any ground loot
you find is black ops only it's not
it ain't it ain't uh there's no modern
warfare guns on the ground
but you can still play with your loadout
that is uh remember on the n64 when you
can do this like it moves with you
that's kind of a crappy kind of a
crappy image whatever
it's not about that we're here to play
and i finally got in so i'm going to
take advantage of this
these views look at
it's my birthday
happy birthday if that's true yeah happy
birthday gab gabby
god adler's face they the textures do
not load fast enough and everyone's
looking blocky during this uh
opening cutscene it's so funny
here we go full squad where we want to
rank who's the squad leader it's not me
battle royale super gassy's closing on
your position suggest
you know what let's do downtown see
what's up see how it's changed
someone is just spamming of course my
last game is with with some spammy
people
allen says i can't get in
this has not been an easy day for a lot
of people we appreciate your patience
all right downtown is this part of
downtown is looking pretty familiar like
these buildings aren't that high but
they they kept touting that it was a lot
less dense so that's
pretty cool although yeah right now it's
looking exactly the same
where's my team okay they're all over
there i'll join them gotta be a good
team player who can make
it longer uh in a match
1911 with the silencer
eric and got the cut scene all right
the one with adler yeah it's not looking
good for him bro
i hear more boxes
alright 83 i like this gun
don't love it i like it scavenger
contract located
roger i thought i was oh i'm blue
never mind never mind all right
hmm yeah this downtown is looking
very samey than it was before
pretty similar
but hey i'm just happy to have gotten
into a game at all hmm
yeah we'll keep that where are my mates
supply box located
[Applause]
two do i need two smgs i do like this
one so i'm gonna use it
all right where's the next scavenger box
what's up there
okay some of it's under construction
it's nice i was really thinking how
just the same it looks this box
self all right the pbsh i will use this
okay this is the new
world war ii weapon that is what added
into the game
it's cool it's a little jumpy but um you
can add attachments i can't believe it
so
soon enough um i'll show you what it
looks like well
i'll show you how it you know works
in-game it's pretty cool
i don't want to waste bullets though
where is this thing wow
can you repel you're losing ground
you climb up this this is the thing in
gta
helicopter
okay well it's been kind of a quiet
start as soon as i say that i'm sure
it'll spice up but um
hopefully you guys are able to get in
and play for yourself if not thanks for
joining us
this whole time
hey this guy got it no
there's the nuke
oh there's a crown down here are we
going to push
i don't know if my team's down to push
they're kind of all scattered i'm not
going to push alone
contract updated new objective
identified
why are we pushing though like don't we
want this guy
all they want to do is uh collapse
collect scavenger packs
where's the nearest shop yeah let's go
put our money together and get a uh
loadout drop
nope another box in here
they're all hanging out they don't want
to hang out with me
might as well just uh go see what
they're up to maybe
into some trouble with these guys
okay now i think enemy team is tracking
your position
primary objective accomplished all
supply boxes found
here someone take my money and put it to
good use
let's take it
excellent now we have enough head for
target location
you've got a loadout drop inbound
friendly uav overhead i will use i'll
use
this class but then i'll swap this out
for the ppsh
probably a dumb move but i want to show
you guys how this uh
plays out this is uh
[Applause]
great let's move on tango
oh the crowd is over there the most one
i think we're finally pushing all right
let's get into some trouble
oh nice
almost over here i have one okay
hmm enemy hilo
we got trouble over here over here
here got movement you're ready strikes
all down
thanks brutal fox
where are they i don't i'm scared to
peek my head out because i got hit from
above last time
maybe
i really don't have the extended life on
this thing
gas is moving in new safe zone
where located they i didn't notice if my
team killed them or not
but all is quiet now the enemy just
wants track of you your sights got
movement no wrong area
you're the loadout got movement
dude just dropped he's weak
all right no bullets in that gun anyway
okay good stuff good stuff
there is a satchel over here if we
almost over here
and if we die we get to show off the new
gulag for you guys
which is now it was modeled after you
know nuketown
before now it's modeled after standoff
second loadout is it safe it's really
open out here
whatever get something with ghost
ak located bounty contract
mp5
i'm thinking too long about this what
the i got kicked out
whatever second one i think i want that
was really pointless but i like the ace
file
i'll keep this i'll keep this load up
you guys saw how the ppsh worked it was
not bad
bounty target identified slot the
bastard
we should head for the safe zone i'd
even pick up a i panicked i didn't get
one with ghosts
let me scout from the top here see
what's going on
yeah i'm glad to have something with a
scope again
pretty important someone's been here it
seems
oh no target location
uber
oh they're right below me oh jeez
crap was that my whole team yeah they're
both in the gulag i let them down
i was trying to scout from above but
then they got hit from right below it
your teammate has entered the gulag
surviving earns them redeployment
okay well see they might come up here
i'll i'll see what happens with the
gulag and then i can buy one of the guys
back if
they don't make it
let me know and chat how it's going if
you're able to get into a game
sounds like it's getting a little more
steady but i don't know
teammate has been cleared for redeploy
oh both these guys
aaron tells me that it's not looking
good in xbox what did you say
waiting for an opponent man it's gonna
be a while
how much uh okay 20 teams left
prepare to fight all right here and you
return to the front line this is gonna
be a really jumpy ak because it has no
stock so
sort them out or capture the objective
you got roughed up in there
oh he went up that's smart
i thought i had shots on influence but
oh well your team can still buy your
back
team's still hanging on let's see what's
going on what's links in the at
uh west links what's the map difference
there's a time
um so maybe you know paw back on the
stream and see
there's a lot of changes but this is
going to be the end of the stream for me
because we lost
drop l's in the chat drop apps what a
day you guys let me uh pan back to
this tada i want to say thank you guys
for
for watching this was a very big day in
call of duty history we are now
playing on verdance only verdank 84 is
the newest map latest and greatest
verdance
2021 has been nuked the rebirth event
the destruction of verdansk has finally
finished
and we are in the swing of season three
so if you've enjoyed uh this
this this live stream gamespot live
drop a like and good luck getting into
the servers today guys i know it's a
little crowded
but appreciate you having here and for
more call of duty coverage
we're always covering it we're always
talking about it keep it right here
to gamespot see you next time guys bye
you